my name is jason silva and i'm very
excited to be here with you guys
today to talk about a very important
revolution happening
a mental health revolution a revolution
being catalyzed by cannabis and
increasingly by
psychedelics we're seeing a world where
we have
a whole new capacity to intervene
to perform a kind of open heart surgery
of the psyche and as dh lawrence wrote
to unleash the brave reckless gods
within us
all but first let's begin with the
problem
right the problem is that according to
the world health organization i think
even the united nation
has written about this 800 000 people a
year now
are committing suicide that's a larger
amount of people
taking their own life than are dying
from natural disasters and armed
conflict
combined so the greatest threat to our
well-being these days is our own minds
we're living through a
epidemic of mental health depression
anxiety
are robbing our lives of our vitality
right we are we are suffering uh an
epidemic of trauma we are fibrillating
we are anxious we are looping we are
stuck in what jamie weil calls these
cul-de-sacs and error
messages we are locked in patterns of
thinking that no longer
serve us we are trapped in reality
tunnels and lenses of perception that
are oppressing us and that we're not
even aware
we're wearing right and these lenses of
perception they color our world they
inform our
world and they're shaped by past trauma
so we bring our baggage
with us to the doorstep of every moment
everything that's ever happened
that slayed us and disappointed us is
absorbed somatically the body
keeps the score and then informs how we
perceive reality so then we see
everything through a prism of
expectation of dread of fear of
apprehension
we pull away we shrink away from the
world something called
jonah syndrome and so these patterns of
thinking
we've over identified with them and we
think that that's
us the monkey mind that inner chatter we
think that's
us but it's not us and so what is needed
is an intervention
a new technology an ecstatic technology
a host of tools
to literally shake the snow globe that's
what robin carthart harris out of the
imperial college of london
that's the term he uses to describe what
psychedelics and what cannabis can do
they shake the snow globe right all
those ski routes
that have been that have been that have
been almost
practically cemented by overuse those
patterns of thinking we can't
shake are finally dissolved by
psychedelics and by
cannabis opening up a space that he
calls a pivotal mental space
of heightened neuroplasticity heightened
suggestibility where we are more
open to be transformed compressing a
decade of psychotherapy
into a singular afternoon we're about to
change
the world on the back of these
technologies we must jump on board now
we must bring the capital we must bring
the investment we must bring
a willingness to change the game of how
we treat mental health
and on that note here's a video about
trauma
about ptsd and about inverse ptsd
so we all know that an experience of
trauma can cause post-traumatic stress
disorder it can be an experience that
marks and fundamentally transforms
the character of a person it can make
them
meet the world with fear so my question
is
is the opposite also true can an
experience of such
radiance of such grace of such
astonishment and beauty be akin to a
kind of
inverse ptsd and can be as fundamentally
transformative to the character
structure of a person
that it now shifts their lenses of
perception to lenses that meet the world
not with
fear but instead with curiosity
right we all have these lenses of
perception we see with our lenses we see
through the lenses
but we don't see the lenses themselves
right
this self-construct this lens of
perception this ego is something that we
mistake
for what we are it's not a fixed
unchanging thing
in fact it's an amalgamation of past
experiences right you become
your experiences your cells are a
technology that turns experience into
biology so essentially
eventually you meet the world through a
prism of expectations
shaped by past trauma past
experience until eventually that lens is
clouding your encounter with the world
so much it's akin to a kind of tunnel
vision
you don't see the world as it is you see
the world as
you are and what if that filter on the
world is not serving you
what if seeing the world as you are is a
dark
[ __ ] lens what if you don't like who
you are
can you change who you are well it turns
out that ego
dissolving experiences can make the
possessor of a lens of perception become
aware that he has a lens of perception
and dispose of that lens of perception
if it no longer
serves them we need encounters with the
numerous experiences that
recontextualize
the self so that you identify not with
the small
self but with the self with a capital s
you stop tuning into the broadcast of
the ego and you tune into the broadcast
of the whole and when you find another
place to plant your feet
my friends when you meet the world from
a different
vantage point you see that you no longer
are tethered to that old monkey suit and
that old monkey mind
and it is through this moment of grace
right that you remember what you forgot
right you fundamentally transformed your
self-system
and perhaps now can meet the world
not with fear but instead with curiosity
you have been absolved
[Music]
yeah you have been absolved
now the world becomes wealthy
a playground
all right so as as you've just seen in
that
video the nature of trauma is
insidious because trauma stays with you
right it's not just the thing that
happens it's not just
the betrayal of a world made
unsafe it's not just being stabbed in
the back
it's this sort of after burn it's the
fact that it stays
in the cells it stays in the body it
pretty much permanently rewires your
nervous system
and tweaks your perception lenses
your expectations about the world so
that now you meet the world through a
prism of fear
you have these lenses of perception
these patterns of thinking that you're
stuck
inside of and you see with those lenses
and you see through those lenses but you
don't actually see the lenses themselves
so the traumas become a part of you but
you don't really realize you're
traumatized
the world has gone dark and you don't
know why
your rational mind knows why but your
intuition doesn't
you're just stuck in a world that's gone
dark and so
we need to find a way of showing you the
light and as that video
said what is needed is an experience of
equal intensity
but it is sort of in in opposition
right rather than something that slays
you intensely
what is needed is an inverse ptsd
experience something that
raises you to the light with the same
ferocity with which you were slayed
by trauma and roland griffiths out of
johns hopkins university first taught me
this phrase inverse
ptsd he said psychedelically mediated
psychotherapy
working with psilocybin for example but
i believe cannabis
can be a great substitute as well and of
course mdma
is that these experiences can open up a
space
for what's called cognitive
re-patterning
fear extinction and memory
reconsolidation
the amygdala seems to kind of go quiet
the fear center of the brain
the the patterns of thinking that you've
over identified with they start to fall
away
the lenses of perception you see with
and through become apparent and you're
like [ __ ]
these lenses don't serve me i can push
them aside
i can switch the song on the jukebox of
my life
and this realization of authorship the
realization that there is
agency that you can change yourself that
you can change your life that you can
steer
internal life you can steer awareness
that you can
shape and author your inner world
is what timothy leary calls internal
freedom and it's what psychedelics and
cannabis can awaken
you see psychedelics and cannabis all
work
in the same way they basically increase
suggestibility
right they they boost receptivity
and and suggest ability and openness to
stimuli
both from within and from without and so
a person who's traumatized and has all
these boundaries around them
they've hardened right they have all
these psychological defense mechanisms
and all this fundamental repression of
the self they're closed
to the world to protect themselves and
psychedelics cast that away
they open us up again they boost the
suggestibility and the receptivity we're
highly
vulnerable in a way we haven't been
since we were traumatized
and so once that vulnerability is there
we can go in
with the right protocols and procedures
and highly
in a highly delicate way with highly
trained psychotherapists and
and carefully thought out spaces and
contexts
all of which will feed into the waking
dream
that is unfolding within the boundaries
of the psyche and the self
you can be remade you can be transformed
i mean this is a whole new kind of
psychotherapy it's a whole
new approach to mental health one that
unleashes the human spirit one that
frees the brave reckless gods within us
all
one that hurls us into the space of
dream
of liminality right like those
transformative
experiences that indigenous societies
used to engender when a boy becomes a
man or a girl becomes a woman
we're creating the stage the sacred
space for apotheosis for
death practices for resurrection where
we slay
our own dragons and slay our own demons
and come back into ourselves and we are
made whole
psychedelics opened up a space for a
kind of psychologically compressed
version of the hero's journey
we recontextualize the self tim duty
wrote we see ourselves instead as a
marvelous
conduit continuity right a marvelous
conduit in the timeless
whole from which molecules and meanings
flow
from neurons to nebula and back again
and once we become one with the light
once we become
starlight we are healed and we are whole
and to the degree that we can create the
protocols procedures and guardrails
to usher in this mental health
revolution we must my friends
we must free ourselves from the
trappings of the mind
and the trauma in our cells right the
issues are in
the tissues as jamie weil has written so
let us
somatically and psychologically remake
ourselves
by planting the seeds of this
psychedelic revolution to alleviate
human suffering
and save our collective soul
okay so mental illness you might think
of mental illness as an
autoimmune disorder of the psyche
the mind that turns against itself
right the story we tell ourselves about
ourselves
is no longer convincing our patterns of
thinking become
self-defeating it's a horrible thing we
become trapped
in negative loops we become oppressed
by patterns of thought that pillage
our inner life both depression anxiety
obsessive-compulsive disorder
and post-traumatic stress disorder all
originate in the same place a brain
that has become too ordered what
neuroscientist robin carthart harris
calls the entropic
brain theory and so what is needed is a
kind of
shaking of the snow globe that gets us
out of this locked-in
syndrome of sorts right we need to shake
the snow globe we need to be reset right
we need to be
literally dissolved new parts of the
brain
need to talk to themselves think of the
ego the organizing principle of the self
in the mind as the freeway the patterns
of thinking that work
for us that map our world until they
become oppressive until they no longer
work and now we're stuck
on the 405 and it's full of traffic and
we're not moving
and it sucks and so what is needed is
for parts of the brain to start
exploring other synaptic pathways
we need to take side roads we need to be
re-thought
we need to be remade we need to be
reborn
this is what psychedelics promised to do
by disrupting the default mode
network psychedelics literalize catalyze
a shaking of the snow globe they open up
what robin carter harris calls
pivotal mental states of heightened
plasticity
and what occurs in these states of
heightened plasticity
is that we can go in and perform an
open-heart surgery of the psyche
what unfolds in those spaces in those
pivotal mental states
is akin to inverse ptsd right it's
entering
god mode it's making deep adjustments
reconciliations right all contradictions
are reconciled and man has surpassed the
gods
right it's a higher level order that
reveals that those contradictions are
actually
reconciled right think of it as the
thesis
and the antithesis and this is the
problem of depression of anxiety
of opposing and conflicting ways of
being in ways of seeing you are not in
congruence you are tied in and out so
you have thesis and antithesis
and the solution doesn't exist in that
dimension of reality what psychedelics
do is they reveal
not just the thesis not just the
antithesis but
the synthesis which is a higher level
order dimension that again reveals that
those paradoxes actually reconcile
and now you see what you've been looking
for whereas once you were blind now you
can see
right all of your desires abolished by
the plenitude of their satisfaction it's
a parting of the seas moment
psychedelics opened up the space for
that to happen
but how do you create spaces for this to
scale how do you create
spaces where thousands hundreds of
thousands millions of people can undergo
these kinds of transformations
how do you synthesize the compound so
that you can have efficacy so you can
control dosing
so you can create the guard rails for
people to experience these pivotal
mental states where they shake the snow
globe well this is where we need
enterprise this is where we need capital
this is where we need
the psychedelic revolution comprised of
startups that are going to change the
world